pasamos a nuestro primer invitado del
día el invierno empieza a cerrarse en
Ucrania aportas de cumplirse un año de
la invasión rusa los enfrentamientos que
parecen entrar en un momento de desgaste
se redefinirán en primavera Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea siguen
aprobando auxilios para boludo y mi
selenski pero será suficiente vamos al
análisis con Jesús Manuel Pérez Triana
él es analista de seguridad y defensa
autor de guerras posmodernas.com y
Franco Sur punto com Jesús Manuel
gracias a usted
muy bien entonces se reactivará la
guerra con el fin del Invierno Usted qué
opina en qué condiciones está el terreno
después del paso de la nieve
Bueno evidentemente hay una acumulación
de fuerzas y materiales para lo que
venga después del Invierno lo estamos
viendo porque la lista de ayuda material
de occidente a ucraniano solo se limita
a los famosos carros leopard sino que
hay toda una serie de materiales
entonces lo que se está esperando es que
termine el invierno y lo que venga será
una fase intermedia de deshielo donde el
suelo se convierte en barro y eso
imposibilita al movimiento de vehículos
pero a continuación todo el mundo lo que
se está esperando es que Ucrania intenta
recuperar el terreno que todavía que
está en manos de Rusia fundamentalmente
en el sur en el corredor terrestre que
conecta con crimea y habrá que ver
también la respuesta rusa después de que
el general herázimos asuma El general
jefe del Estado Mayor de las fuerzas
suma las responsabilidades de lo que
allí se llama operación militar especial
mire usted hablaba hace un momento de
los tanques Y es que estos vehículos han
sido protagonistas durante la última
semana de las noticias pueden realmente
estos tanques cambiar el ritmo de la
guerra y si no pues Cuáles son las armas
que necesita que fue para mejorar su
posición en esta ofensiva
a ver lo que cree Ucrania es llevar la
iniciativa en la primera fase de la
guerra vimos que habían recibido
armamento anticarro portátil para que
las fuerzas ligeras obreras emboscaran a
los rusos en la segunda fase vimos que
habían recibido artillería y ahora para
llevarla habían sido artillería para los
vuelos que sucediendo entre las fuerzas
en el dogmas pero ahora para llevar la
iniciativa para salir a campo abierto
para asaltar las posiciones rusas y
recuperar terreno para poder llevar a la
iniciativa necesitan fuerzas mecanizadas
y eso no solamente son capas de combate
o tanque sino también son vehículos de
combate Infantería Y ambos están en la
lista de material que van a recibir
Ucrania la cuestión importante aquí es
la cantidad vamos a ver cuánto del
material porque ya no estamos hablando
de excedentes de la vieja guerra fría
sino del propio material que tienen las
fuerzas armadas occidentales en sus
propios ejércitos y están dispuestos a
entregar las Ucrania vamos a ver cómo
las emplean los los ucranianos y sobre
todo y otra cosa importante si está
dando mucha importancia al carro de
combate o leopardos que podría cambiar
la guerra pero en realidad del carro de
combate hay muchas versiones de la
segunda versión Habría que ver cuál de
los modelos que se entrega y cuál va a
ser entonces la diferencia en tecnología
de entre Esos carros que se entregan y
los modelos rusos en el caso de los más
abundantes son los excedentes de la
vieja guerra fría yo no creo que haya
tanta diferencia con rusos de primera
nueva generación en el caso de los
últimos modelos occidentales hay una
diferencia considerable entre la
tecnología occidental y rusa entonces
habrá que ver cómo de generosos son los
occidentes sorpresa occidentales
entregando material viejo o realmente
nuevo y capaz de cambiar
las capacidades de los equilibrio entre
Ucrania y Rusia mire hace casi un año la
expectativa de Rusia era una guerra
flash o una incursión rápida y finalizar
el conflicto eso no pasó y lo que hizo
fue que la guerra se convirtiera en un
flujo de recursos constante y una
carrera contra el tiempo está occidente
en capacidad de proveer aquí F por
encima de la capacidad rusa porque es
que ya llevamos casi un año de entregas
de auxilios en diferentes proporciones y
maneras
Bueno pues hay una preocupación notable
en todo occidente primero porque se han
ido agotando muchos de los depósitos de
municiones por ejemplo se había buscado
mucha mucho material excedente de la de
la vieja guerra fría porque era la
tecnología con la que estaban
familiarizados y con la que contaban
Ucrania luego se le ha entregado
material occidental por ejemplo las
piezas de artillerías que mencionaba en
esos vuelos de artillería en el doma y
lo vamos encontrando que la capacidad de
producción de occidente pues no está a
la altura de una de una guerra de alta
intensidad y lo que hemos visto es que
los países donantes han buscado ayuda
militar en Bueno o sea se ha salido al
mercado internacional a comprar stocks a
comprar arsenales y si se ha determinado
buscando lugares inéditos como por
ejemplo hasta Pakistán y uganda que
tenían materiales que podrían ser usados
en esa guerra entonces lo que por otro
lado También estamos viendo que las
sanciones internacionales le ponen un
problema a a Rusia para poder fabricar
mucha de los sin mucho de su armamento
porque utiliza piezas occidentales O sea
que es una situación equilibrada tienen
problemas vamos a ver quién es el que
resuelve en el caso de la industria rusa
era buscar sustitutos alternativas de
tecnología china en el caso de occidente
pues está sentando con la industria o
sea por ejemplo en el caso del pentágono
en Estados Unidos o sentado con la
industria a ver qué se puede hacer para
multiplicar para aumentar las líneas de
producción y eso es una preocupación que
todavía vemos que está ahí vamos a ver
cómo se resuelve porque evidentemente la
industria le interesa pues vender sus
productos pero no crear líneas de
producción que luego cuando acabe la
guerra pues queden se sean excedentarias
Entonces es un problema que tienen ambos
bueno mire y en las últimas
declaraciones el presidente ruso ha
insistido en que el curso de la guerra
tiene tiene el camino esperado Usted qué
opina acerca de eso
bueno en el caso de Ucrania ya lo
anticipaban que cuando llegas el
invierno se iba a paralizar las acciones
militares vemos que la guerra
efectivamente se ha estancado y las
operaciones militares están teniendo
lugar en dos en una zona así vemos el
mapa de Ucrania lo grande que es y todo
se concentran en un sitio muy pequeño en
las ciudades hasta hace poco soledad
Entonces estamos en esa fase de pausa
los ucranianos todavía piensan que
tienen capacidad para recuperar terreno
perdido decir No veremos que ambos
bandos se sientan en la mesa de
negociación Hasta que por lo menos los
ucranianos agoten toda la las
capacidades las ganas la energía los
recursos hasta que no lleguen a una
situación de agotamiento y piensen que
ya no es posible a seguir recuperando
terreno o que de seguir la guerra van a
va a ser perjudicial para ellos porque
los rusos van a poder seguir avanzando
entonces en el caso ruso les valdría
acabar la guerra ahora mismo porque
habrían conseguido algunas ventajas
territoriales no lo que pensaban al
comienzo de la guerra han tenido que
pasar al Plan B de haber saltado la
capital y haber cambiado el gobierno
ahora se limitan a una conquista
territorial Entonces todavía a ver que
los ucranianos gasten el ímpetu Las
ganas las reservas en la y la voluntad
de la sociedad ucraniana de que todavía
hay que recuperar más terreno cuando eso
suceda en esta Primavera ya veremos
Entonces si la guerra entre una fase de
estancamiento o ya directamente ambos
bandos empiezan a crear canales
discretos diplomáticos para sentarse a
la mesa de negociación y acabar la
guerra